[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi dio sono fa vj siamo tornati
ragazzi su sixty seconds come ragazzo è
sempre un gioco di sopravvivenza mi sono
attrezzato con i biscotti perché mi
piace vederli morire mentre quando non
mai visto un disegno più merdoso di sta
roba che fa bravo figlio tutto dentro
tutto dentro figlia inutile del cazzo
vieni qua questa ragazza è la parte che
mi mette più in ansia in assoluto perché
non ha senso c'è mio figlio con la merda
di secolo guardava e vai vai vai vai vai
no no no perfetto vai c'è un fucile su
luogo al cielo le missioni o pre termini
siano i non lo so mi ricordo prendilo
cazzo
ecco ecco come sul cazzo di acqua no
si no oddio oddio minchio perso degli
anni di vita ragazzi non chiedetemi come
ho fatto non ne ho idea allora ragazzi
vi vedo belli carichi vediamo se
riusciamo a fare un qualcosa di decente
con due fottute bot che sei salvo per
adesso è grazie al cazzo siamo appena
scesi è successo ma chi cazzo succede
reagan sidro ma vi drogate non ha
seriamente l'avevo capito rifacciamo che
a me l'accordo ragazzi son tornato
dentro col triplo delle cose non
chiedetemi come ho fatto perché non ne
ho idea munizioni armi ciò di tutto
quindi ragazzi partiamo per questa volta
c'è un bordello dirò non ho mai fatto
una partenza così bella
partiamo come si deve fare un qualcosa
di decente mi avete detto mi avete dato
alcune dritte qua continua non dargli da
mangiare man comune a morire
l'immondizia si sta riempiendo di zucche
vuote ma se non gli ho dato un cazzo che
costa dicendo che stanno già
l'immondizia piena ma che non ho
mangiato niente tu porca [ __ ]
ok è ragazzi c'è una lira o mio dio
quell affare enorme sono scarpe schifo
effettivamente cioè un problema il fatto
che ci siano scarafaggi comunque
abilioni mandarlo zio in spedizione
perfetto comunque ragazzi è un problema
se ci sono degli scarafaggi grossi come
godzilla qualcuno mi spiega come li
mandiamo via si scarafaggino perché una
roba indecente non ve lo voglio dire che
poi non si muovono sono sempre lì va bè
questo punto vi mando anche loro in
spedizione ormai vincono sono uno
scarafaggio mutante
asca scalea francesca scarpa giusta
pinging non e sto dando da mangiare da
giorni stanno reggendo ragazza avevate
ragione gruppo di persone vestite come
un pigiama verde stanno bussando alla
prova cosa stanno dicendo di essere dei
merry men dicono che vogliono prendere
dai ricchi per dare ai poveri noi siamo
molto poveri quindi possiamo farci gli
amici dovremmo lasciarla entrare se
permette di far centrali potrebbero o
derubarci di brutto pure potrebbero
darci una mano ma [ __ ] e non ho
bisogno di un cazzo latrine affanculo
tutti abbiamo imparato una lezione
recentemente se non fai niente per
quanto riguarda gli scarafaggi in casa
tua
lì rai con l'avere più scarafaggi ok
allora facciamo che uccide lì col fucile
sti stronzi bisogna usare un fucile per
degli scarafaggi di merda
vabbè ha funzionato ragazzi non si sa
come ma potevi usare l'ascia a questo
punto che cazzo uso il fucile la tua
salute e tornato è tornato lo stronzo
perfetta preso della zuppa miglia cos'è
questo hai portato del buon tavernello
zio ma passo mandarne due fuori non solo
brava e mary jane vai fuori se un giorno
dieci non hanno mai arrivato così a con
tutta sta roba dopo tutti i giorni
cambiano speso per stare qua non siamo
proprio puliti saranno alternative da
considerare vabbè come l'ultima volta il
problema è che non c'era la bombola
piace al soggetto nei proiettili che
cosa fate l'infini nel culo che cosa
c'entrano i proiettili con la polizia
hanno capito ma seriamente ragazzo se sì
cosa che cosa è servito così abbiamo
utilizzato la polvere da sparo per
profumarsi ma che problemi avete al
cervello siamo stiamo resistendo
veramente un casi è tornata grazie a dio
l'obeso è tornata stai male c'è qualcosa
che possiamo fare utilizzare una radio
per prendere alcuni alcuni segnali che
potrebbero essere trasmessi nella nostra
area
ho capito ma il problema è che non
abbiamo una radio ci ha portato più due
di zuppa perfetto e touch è andato anche
più due di acqua ma che è vivo anche più
e va beh da dove cazzo hai rapinato una
farmacia abbiamo trovato una cesta piena
di di tostapane
ok e dopo avere speso del tempo
giocherellando con quei cosi abbiamo
finito per creare una radio che funziona
occasionalmente ma come ave mary jane ha
bisogno di cibo timi ha bisogno di cibo
dolores ha bisogno di cibo e tende ha
bisogno di cibo quindi che cazzo
facciamo noi andiamo un pene ragazzi
giorno 17 io non ho parole non so come
cazzo ho fatto che bellabarba ragazzi io
direi un po di acqua e cibo attimi anche
se sta bene così lo mandiamo fuori la
prossima volta perché sennò non mandiamo
fuori di nessuno
possiamo che vogliono accendere la radio
per vedere se riescono a captare delle
frequenze anche l'oro vale dai
accendiamo st radio sonora che ogni
tanto si sente che odioso cos'è lo
sapevamo e hanno detto che in una
manciata di giorni saranno qua e là
hanno detto di aspettare per futuri
istruzioni fantastico se riesco madara
gal 21 21 giorni e sto messo non neanche
troppo male dovrebbe essere più
tranquillo andare in superficie adesso
quindi possiamo andare qualcuno fuori no
perché non c'è un voglia si strinse con
quasi impazziti perché il rifugio era
pieno di insetti e peggio sono sono
ragni forza ma forse li possiamo usare
il fucile dobbiamo fare qualcosa
riguardo quelli e che cazzo ne so ma che
cosa li vuoi dare la pizza usa lascia
che cazzo xi il kit medico voli
schiacciarli col kit medico ragazzi ho
battuto il mio record giorno 23 pd così
non sono mai andato magari non sono
ragni e sono solo allucinazione a a loro
che è un po di pillole possono aiutare
ha funzionato un humor spider ma vero
questo si sogna i ragni ma [ __ ]
acqua tutti acqua tutti oggi parti vodka
e belvedere si possa andar fuori grandi
regalo da fermo che gli do il cibo a lui
già sopra quanto li adoro kimi è andato
fuori perfetto andato fuori speriamo che
si sia ripreso povero cristiano ed è
proprio un tag live vivente a lui non
gliene frega un cazzo è come se fosse
andato a trovarla nome lo stato in grado
di ricevere un altro messaggio i
militari stanno preparando la missione
di soccorso vogliono che tutti
sopravvissuti specifichino la propria
zona è ma non c'è la mappa ma non ci
credo
vabbè non ce l'abbiamo la mappa cazzo
cazzo cazzo no non ci credo non ho
portato la mappa che deficente come ho
fatto non portare la mappa rega c'è solo
toccata e se tranquillanti emozionale
eravamo sicuri di poter trovare una zona
senza una mappa ma stavamo sbagliando il
ci credo mai ci credo mai dai timidi
micai portato una mappa ti sei andato
all'esselunga ragazzi devo dare
dell'acqua a tutti il problema che non
ne rimane praticamente più un cazzo
quindi o ce la facciamo ce la facciamo
che di e vigoroso abbastanza per andare
nel west line perfetto baite di facci
sognare ted facci sognare giorno 28
perfetto tracciare la figlia è morta è
morta di fame ma no con tutto quel cibo
che gli ho dato macro
le persone da sfamare [ __ ] segnate
visto che un giorno 37 che cazzo mai più
nella vita riusciva fa una roba così non
mandiamo a fare la madre brava fuori dai
[ __ ] perfetto io non so perché sono
convinto che la madre passerà da zara
invece di prendere le provviste tornerà
quei vestiti del tipo amo regolamento
son bella fortunatamente abbiamo nasce
stavamo per andare a dormire quando
hanno sentito qualcuno bussare alla
porta e come hanno fatto a sopravvivere
alla bomba nucleare dovremmo aprire ma
dai per una volta ci provo [ __ ]
voglio arrivare alla 40 non mi uccidere
stronzo non mi ha ucciso non mi ha
ucciso ben è importante questo chi era
bottiglia tv ragazzi un gruppo di
viaggiatori stava indossando lega
smaschera un altro figlio e di acqua che
culotte da fame è un piede nella fossa
guardiamo acqua e cibo a tutti ma si
conta romica passiamo organi ai ragazzi
se avete voglia facciamo aster vinita
casa mia ci penso io vanta ben di dio
cioè giorno 40 40 last man standing e
minchia viola d'oro
la adoro amica mi ha appena usciamo
andiamo dai cieli mt compro tutto
quarantesimo giorno è tornata con la
mappa non ci credo stavo scherzando zia
stanno scherzando ma i ragazzi ce la
farò mai a finire un cazzo di episodio
di sixty 6 con senza che mi arrivi la
pizza la zona quanta merda portato e io
manderei team in spedizione che l'ultimo
che rimane quindi va beh quando un
mattone è caduto dal muro rivelando una
piccola apertura inesistenti sono stati
invasi da un terribile odore va beh
dobbiamo guardare dentro quel buco e
vedere qual è la l'origine di
quell'odore no proprio no nella vita
potrebbe essere anche mia zia che vi
assicuro puzza buongiorno 43 di un mese
e mezzo qua dentro sempre comunque
meglio che andare a scuola uno straniero
ha portato a ok vuole fare il rischio
dei baratti si offre un acqua per le
carte cazzo ne faccio del ca la torcia
cazzo me ne faccio la torcia ma
[ __ ] a torres non serve la torcia
convinto col culo che cioè rega che ora
guarda il culo dolores porrebbe mangiare
qualcosa vorra che non ci serve la
torcia e son convinto lo sapevo non è
possibile che qualcosa vada male col
sistema di ventilazione dobbiamo
investigare prima di soffocare cosa
facciamo mai usiamo questo che non è
e che cazzo possa servire ma vabbè ho
deciso di spruzzare dello spray
eccessivamente degli insetti mutanti
sono usciti fuori e abbiamo gustato
dell'aria fresca
sì sì cazzo di militari arrivano no
giorno 53 ma ce la fanno
io ho compreso che dolore se
completamente impazzita bene io non ce
lo mando fuori su cristiano lega no non
ce lo mando fuori mi dispiace non lo
voglio mandare fuori
ora che è diventato da in bild serie
white ed ora come ti sto riempiendo tese
non torni ti ammazzo io giorno 60
ragazzi che è successo è tornato chi è
tornato è tornato luglio è stata un
altro annuncio militare alla radio
i soldati sembrano vicini dai dai dai
caf di militari dai quanto ci mettete 69
che non è un kamasutra giorno 70 ragazzi
ma ce la fanno
qualcuno sta bussando alla porta non
abbiamo sentito che cosa voleva dire
abbiamo aprire la porta apriamo siamo
ormai al 70esimo giorno cazzo abbiamo
fare sono i militari porca di quella
[ __ ] ladra [ __ ] vaio gli
stranieri probabilmente banditi hanno
cercato non ci credo hanno detto che
hanno catturato una donna e la
descrizione sembrava quella di colore
qualche qua da chi cazzo [ __ ] non ci
credo cosa c'è un [ __ ] rega tutto non
ho più cazzo ma dai hanno ucciso dolore
e se c'è un [ __ ] tutto te devi
ammazzarli di schiaffi 72 guarda come
assetato affamato pazzo stanco e
affaticato eva bere tanta acqua ancora
non è morto militari non si sono fatti
vedere neanche una cazzo di ma guarda
che bello che zio bobby troppi giorni
senza acqua né cibo ma mica c'è un
[ __ ] la vita che cazzo dovevamo fare
una conta roba è una cosa che non si
ripeterà mai più nella vita di resistere
così tanto ma va bene se abbiamo
imparato una lezione da questa cosa che
i militari quando ci sono delle stragi
nucleari sono dei bastardi di me siamo
rimasti senza acqua senza munizioni
senza armi senza cibo ma grazie a dio
ancora la mia pitti sarà raffreddata
perché ho passato tipo ore a giocare a
sta roba senza mangiare un cazzo che
ragazzi concluso primo episodio spero
che vi sia piaciuto anche perché durante
la durata la vita quindi ragazzi servizi
è piaciuto ma solitamente mi piace non
mi piace per i militari di merda che non
si sono fatti vedere manca una cazzo di
volta se volessi di sky ci vediamo al
prossimo video delle ragazze